dans le journal du dimanche marion
maréchal-le pen attaque frontalement
marine le pen mais surtout florian
philippot critiquée pour avoir proposé
de revenir sur le remboursement intégral
est illimité de l'avortement la députée
frontistes ne retient plus ses coups
après ce que vous leur dites ici ce
matin si la cour de récréation ça suffit
non je dis à tout le monde
les électeurs ne nous pardonneront pas
alors qu'ils espèrent tant en nous nous
pardonnons pas de tomber dans des
chicanes
vous avez peur ils n'ont pas compris
parce que nous avons déjà nous pris les
risques que vous avez pris des risques
pour beaucoup je sais que certains ont
pu dépression on tue même plus que ça
certains ont été punis je sais ça les
avait subi des pressions pour renoncer
on va il ya plein de gens qui vous
disent non ce serait mieux qu'il soit ma
bâtonnets juifs avant moi vous savez
dépression j'en ai eu toute ma vie
vous alliez le faire gagner parce que
c'est notre projet
hélas public
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu l'archétype classique de
l'image qu'on veut donner du politique
qui hurlent et qui va remporter des
suffrages comme ça je renverrai bien aux
images du loup de wall street un très
beau film de martin scorsese il ya
certes un certain écho avec ces images
pas seulement dans la forme mais aussi
dans le fond quelqu'un qui dit aux
traders avec qui il travaille je veux
vous gagnez de l'argent c'est un petit
peu ça le projet d' emmanuel macron je
pense pour la jeunesse de ce pays
car comme disait la chanson je suis
comme je suis alors à propos il fait
comme ça ap donc les français me
prendront ou pas ainsi emmanuel macron
était surtout attendu sur le fond
aujourd'hui voici sa réponse parce que
je veux être le candidat de la justice
j'ai suis le candidat du travail quand
j'ai été ministre je ne considère pas
que c'était mes conseillers ou mon
directeur de cabinet qui était
responsable de ce que j'ai mal fait ils
m'ont toujours bien conseillé c'est la
faim moi qui ai pris parfois des
mauvaises décisions parce que j'ai eu
aussi des échecs avec une extrême droite
aux portes du pouvoir et le programme
particulièrement dur de françois fillon
qui incarne une droite rétrécit et
rabougri ma responsabilité est de créer
l'unité fin de citation êtes vous
candidat à la primaire de la gauche
oui vous y attendez quatre cent mille
visiteurs mais parce que vous êtes
modeste en dordogne
vous en aurez bien davantage je ne parle
pas de la visite du président de la
république c'est fait il y en aura
peut-être d'autres qui viendront mais
j'ai l'exclusivité de l'inauguration par
je ne pars pas dans cette primaire
uniquement même pour gagner la primaire
je veux que nous puissions gagner la
présidentielle
[Musique]